the strike happened in the early
afternoon local time as residents in the
small town of pervamasky were gathered
for a military funeral
the blast wounding dozens including
children among them infants
we can assume this was a missile strike
as a consequence more than half of the
neighborhood is not fit to live in
anymore
cars were set Ablaze and the windows of
surrounding apartment buildings blown in
was blown out
local officials have accused Russian
forces of deliberately targeting the
funeral that was being held for a local
Soldier killed in the fighting around
the eastern city of bakmut
today residents of our town as well as
brothers in arms from different units
had gathered for the funeral of Ole
fentonenko who was an outstanding person
Russia denies deliberately targeting
civilians Rob McBride Al Jazeera Keith